a new US government report finds
hospitals face a combination of problems
slow testing equipment shortages and
staff burnout that make it much harder
to deal with the coronavirus and now
there's one more problem many of these
hospitals are suddenly losing revenue
our consumer investigative correspondent
Anna Werner shows us how hospitals are
trying to reduce costs by if you can
believe it temporarily cutting staff in
Florida at Miami Dade County's Jackson
Memorial Hospital executives say they're
taking pay cuts and other employees are
being asked to go on temporary furloughs
due to the financial strain required
Arion case manager Angela freshly
Fairchild was surprised to receive an
email saying she would be mandated to
take a week off in the middle of the
crisis couldn't understand it because
all around the country they're asking
for nurses right now they're asking for
health care workers to work in
facilities that are dying with the
increased numbers of coronavirus cases
the ripple effects of preparing for the
corona virus are hitting hospitals
around the country Boston Medical Center
health system temporarily furloughed
some 700 employees a Health System in
Sarasota Florida said its revenue
dropped by 16 million dollars in March
it's following some employees trimming
hours for others similar cuts are in
place at a Syracuse New York Hospital
the problems are reflected in a new
nationwide survey of hospitals from the
Inspector General for HHS and Maxwell is
an assistant i G
was in order to prepare appropriately
for taking care of this infectious
disease the hospitals have stopped
elective procedures which bring in money
to the hospital they've stopped other
procedures as well so they're losing
revenue back in Miami the CEO of the
Jackson Health System which runs Jackson
Memorial is Carlos McGuire
he says the answers are in the math
where Public Health System our operating
margins are really really tiny
we don't make a whole lot of money and
we don't have at the huge working
capital of a lot of for-profit health
care systems he says since his hospital
have stopped doing most elective
surgeries his system has lost 40% of its
revenue and predicts it will lose 25
million dollars in the month of April
alone so he says he's keeping frontline
doctors and nurses but cutting wherever
else he can when do you think some of
these hospitals might hit bottom
we're already hitting bottom the moment
that the revenue stopped coming in the
bottom is already there we just don't
know
for how long a period of time some
hospitals indicate that they can and
will call workers back when the need
becomes greatest here but McCoy says it
would help them a lot if they knew when
the federal stimulus money that
hospitals are expecting was going to
come in he says it could take months in
response to this report by the IG by the
way the Health and Human Services
spokesperson said they are working hard
to support local communities Gail boyana
this is a head scratcher because this is
such a hands on deck situation and their
skills are so needed at this time thank
you thank you very much